昨天的創新案例讓我很驚訝，你知道現在連資料中心都要搬到海上了嗎？
沒錯，這個案例確實很有意思。為了應對AI對能源和散熱的巨大需求，這家新創公司，投資者給了他們 1.4 億美元，打算把資料中心搬到海上。
1.4 億美元，這可不是小數目。一般公司怎麼會想到在陸地上建不就好了嗎？陸地上至少比較穩定啊。
這就是它出乎意料的地方。傳統資料中心需要大量電力，而且運作時會產生巨大的熱能，散熱也是一大挑戰。在陸地，這些問題的成本都很高。
我懂了，就像我們家冷氣開久了，電費會爆表，還會熱呼呼的。那他們具體是怎麼解決這些問題的？
他們的做法是把伺服器機房建在遠離海岸的海上，利用海浪來發電，並且用海水來冷卻。網路連接則透過衛星。
哇，利用波浪發電和海水冷卻，這真的很聰明耶！等於是把自然資源直接變成他們的成本優勢。
是的，這樣一來，他們不僅解決了能源供應的問題，還省去了陸上昂貴的散熱系統。同時也避免了陸地空間有限的問題。
這樣聽起來，這不僅是環保，還大大降低了營運成本。對於創業者或主管來說，這裡面有什麼值得學習的地方嗎？
對於創業者或主管來說，這個案例最大的啟示是，當你面臨一個極端挑戰時，比如高耗能、高成本，不要只在現有的框架裡找答案。
他們跳脫了「資料中心必須在陸地」這個常識，大膽地結合了海洋工程和科技。這種跨界思考，能催生出兼顧永續與效率的顛覆性解決方案。
所以，當我們遇到問題的時候，不要只想到眼前的解決方案，可以試著從完全不同的領域去借鑒、去組合，也許會有意想不到的突破。
沒錯。就像這個案例，面對AI帶來的巨大能源壓力，他們不只專注於提高效率，而是重新定義了基礎設施的可能。
那對於我們一般上班族，這個概念可以怎麼帶到工作或生活中呢？我們又沒有什麼「伺服器」可以搬到海上。
雖然我們沒有資料中心，但這個思考模式很有價值。比如，你發現工作中有個環節特別耗時耗力，與其想辦法壓縮時間，不如想想有沒有完全不同的流程或工具可以用。
就像我常常要跑公文，與其抱怨公文很慢，不如想想有沒有線上系統或自動化工具可以導入，也許就能省下很多精力。
對，甚至生活中，如果你覺得通勤很累，可能不是要想怎麼在路上多睡幾分鐘，而是考慮遠距工作，或者找個離家更近的地方。
這樣一來，就好像把「問題」搬到另一個更適合解決的地方一樣，而不是硬扛。這個洞察力讓我很有收穫。
就是這個意思。當我們遇到一個難題時，試著把眼光放遠一點，跳出原有的限制去思考，你會發現解決方案可能遠比你想像的要多。
我覺得這個「原來可以這樣！」的感受特別強烈。當我們面對資源或空間限制時，這種跳脫框架的思維真的很關鍵。
對，它告訴我們，解決方案不一定在問題本身內部，有時你需要的只是換個地方、換個維度去看待它。
聽完這個案例，我突然覺得很多困難似乎都有了新的解決方向。下次遇到瓶頸，我會試著這樣想。
我想這也是這個案例最啟發人的地方。它提供了一個大膽的視野，讓我們看到解決問題的更多可能性。